viernes y para el cierre de la semana
también hablamos de economía y por eso
hasta que en el estudio jorge hurtado
jorge vamos a comenzar hablando y
analizando en detalle la caída
generalizada del mercado de las cripto
monedas asia y bueno esta semana el
bitcoin que es la cripto moneda más
famosa descendió a los 29 mil dólares el
bitcoin ha perdido el 50 por ciento de
su valor en los últimos seis meses desde
los máximos que alcanzó el noviembre
pasado cuando se sitúa cerca de los 70
mil dólares pero para entender el tamaño
de un mercado se debe revisar la
capitalización de mercado o sea qué
valor o cuánto dinero ha invertido en
cripto moneda en su punto álgido en
noviembre de santiago todo el mercado de
cripto monedas estaba valorado en 3,1
billones de dólares según los datos de
yo inyectó esta semana ese mes ese mismo
mercado cayó a 13 billones de dólares
para darnos una idea la pérdida de valor
del mercado es de casi 2 billones de
dólares cómo se explica este desplome se
lo preguntamos andrés jiménez él es hijo
y fundador de freedom una empresa
especializada en la tecnología blaustein
la coyuntura global todo lo viene
pasando desde diciembre a la fecha con
la invasión de rusia ucrania entonces de
alguna manera cuando siempre hay riesgo
en los mercados lo que hacen los
inversionistas profesionales es retirar
dinero de este tipo de inversiones que
representan riesgo y por lo tanto hace
parte digamos de esas caídas que han
venido sucediendo la segunda y digamos
que es una muy importante y también es
valioso que lo intentamos es la
correlación que han tenido el bitcoin
principalmente con los mercados de
riesgo como lo pueden ser las acciones
es principalmente con eeuu standard and
poor's in hasta que esa correlación que
entre en términos técnicos se refiere al
beta ha sido por encima incluso del 50
por ciento es decir que los movimientos
a la baja que han tenido las acciones
americanas tanto el vídeo como la script
o monedas lo siguen de manera muy muy
parejo entonces esa es otra de las
grandes digamos que razones por las
cuales hemos venido también sufriendo
esa caída en el tema de crédito porque
también en acciones venimos sufriendo
esa caída desde noviembre
y para mí también muy importante esto lo
que tiene que ver con el ciclo económico
tanto en el corto como el de mediano
plazo y bueno esta gente va un poco más
que se extiende pero la conclusión final
de ese tema es simple es que nos
encontramos en esa parte del ciclo del
cual vamos a y de alguna forma
algunas personas hablan no solamente en
la super inflación que está andino
incluso posibles estanflación es que se
puedan llegar a dar y esto
posteriormente pues la posible recesión
al final jorge como todas las
inversiones tienen su riesgo pero
bitcoin no es la única cripto moneda que
ha perdido su valor de cual otras
estamos hablando estos días el caso más
particular fue el de tierra luna esa
moneda registró una caída de casi el 100
por ciento de su valor en 24 horas según
ccoo embase y tuvo que recibir un
rescate de la cripto minera generó aún
más pesimismo en los mercados porque es
considerado un estado y con una moneda
estable algunos proyectos como éste
están asociados al valor de una moneda
como el dólar o el euro pueden estar
vinculados también a bienes materiales
como el oro o los inmuebles con el fin
de reducir esta volatilidad de los
mercados de crédito moneda le
preguntamos a nuestro invitado que pasó
con tierra que era considerada una
script o moneda estable digamos que lo
que pasó con tierra fue un gran digamos
que no solo descalabro para muchos
inversionistas y que nos dolió a nivel
económico sino también porque confiamos
en este proyecto para toda la industria
de créditos en los afectó esta gran
caída de uno de los proyectos al cual
más le creyentes sin embargo también es
momento para reevaluar en cómo están las
inversiones antes de eso vamos a las
parteras de 'estable' coins que de
alguna manera puede ser monedas estables
que su premisa valor es que su precio se
comporta igual que una moneda fría o una
moneda de intercambio en común como lo
puede ser por ejemplo el dólar entonces
directamente la moneda estable digamos
detente o sleepy empezó a fluctuar un
poquito más su precio e incluso llegó a
valer menos de lo que debería estar
costando sólo porque ya otros proyectos
de monedas estables como tierra se
vieron afectados entonces también es
importante empezar a analizar en cuáles
proyectos que tenemos nuestro capital y
así también poder hacer una
diversificación y no solamente algo que
es un tipo de stage burgos y después
multi en múltiples proyectos de monedas
estables con en algún futuro por alguna
de estas otras monedas no podamos y no
arriesguemos nuestro capital de esta red
jorge entonces cuál es el panorama para
los entusiastas y quienes han invertido
en bitcoins bueno para muchos expertos
aunque esta pérdida es considerable se
produce en activos que de alguna forma
habían sido inflados la asociación blau
ching en la cámara de comercio digital
de eeuu ahora están bajo la lupa del
capitolio hay señales de regulación que
también suman a estas pérdidas que para
muchos pueden convertirse en algunas
oportunidades nuestro invitado asegura
que aunque no hemos visto lo peor no es
el final de la script o monedas y mucho
menos de la tecnología blaustein es muy
probable que el bitcoin llegue incluso a
perder más de un 30% de su valor en el
escenario yo diría que hemos generado
esto significa que de los 30 mil dólares
que se encuentra actualmente pueda
llegar incluso a unos 20 21 mil dólares
como piso e incluso empiecen a georgia
un poco más
al llegar a los mil 718 mil dólares en
el caso de tele aunque la siguiente
moneda más grande de las criptas si
podemos estar viendo un retroceso una
caída por encima del 40 45%
jorge muchas gracias por esta
explicación buen fin de semana para
ustedes aquí continuamos en directo
américa ya viene con 19 de la semana en
américa siga con nosotros